[Applause]
dude this matrix
co-creator confirms that the story is a
trans allegory so
the what chotsky brothers i think now
they're sisters
that now they're the sisters right but
when they made the film i believe they
were the brothers
and um unbelievable filmmakers so
[ __ ] first matrix is one of the best
movies in my lifetime and so unique
oh yeah like so many jokes now exist
because of the matrix like the slow
moving thing like
all these things that all the ways that
they've influenced action
film yeah all these things have come
from the major literally the
like alt-right angle of like oh you to
wake up you got to stop [ __ ]
red pill from two trans filmmakers
unbelievable yeah i mean what do you
think they think about that that's
hilarious
it's still red pilled or is that the
pill they take when you find out
you slept with a trans person that's
what the film is you take the pill that
you're gonna vote for from now on the
red one
but dude so it's it's they're these
these
incredibly innovative filmmakers they
did this incredibly
amazing series i mean the matrix is one
of my favorite trilogies of all time
i think probably my favorite maybe lord
of the rings
it's between the lord of the rings
matrix is [ __ ] unbelievable and
they become or they always are trans
they actually transition
right so now they're the sisters right
wachotsky sisters i'm [ __ ] up the
last name
wycotsky you're getting sisters right
that's the important part yeah sisters
what they care about
um and now they're saying that the
matrix was always an allegory
for being trans right which i don't
understand how
i don't think they fully thought this
through
which part
from what i see what i read it's like
you're trapped in between two worlds and
then you become who you really are in
the matrix or like when you step out of
the matrix
so i guess that's like when you
transition that world sucks
it's flavorless it's gray it's drab
there's nothing to any of it
so if you're really trying to make trans
people feel free
wouldn't you being free be lit as [ __ ]
and not
boring and and colorless and [ __ ]
food has no taste all of it when you're
pretending to be what you're not
life is pretty good yeah you don't have
to do a [ __ ] steak and you're wearing
any clothes you want
if that's the allegory the the allegory
you should never transition yeah
i think that's what the point would come
across as right like we all watched the
movie the matrix and we're like it is
way better to be in the
blue pill yeah blue pill is way better
yeah yeah red pill you understand what
life really is
but it sucks you don't want to know what
the sausage is made out of yeah
right like that's why that's saying
exists yeah i
i don't want the [ __ ] thing in the
back of my head letting me know that i
was plugged into some [ __ ] yeah
ignorance is bliss ignorance is bliss
that said that in the movie no but
what's interesting
is i wonder if it tracks and this is
something they did retroactively
i wonder if now it's a reflection of how
they feel about
being trans
right i wonder i my take is i think it's
complete [ __ ]
and they're just trying to add it yeah
you add just another
layer it's like the joke okay rolling
[ __ ] yeah you add another layer on top
of the movie and now it's like wow
well to your point like when they make
cartoons gay and [ __ ] they're just like
uh yeah the cartoon was trans
well to your point you know what they
announced recently there's a matrix four
yeah
so this would be good pr for that movie
and would get you back in the headlines
ooh who's going to play is it going to
be neo or everybody's back
i don't know if morpheus is back but the
shorty is back
and um and keanu's back oh they said
switch was supposed to be
like a representation of trans you
remember the short hair blonde girl
yes they were they're like kind of
playing they wouldn't let her fully do
it but they wanted her to be
male in the real world and female yes in
the matrix or
vice versa but then the studio said no
studio said no so they kind of like
tried to sneak it in there that she's
kind of like
androgynous a little bit with the short
blonde hair and she's like this badass
shooting there's not things you
traditionally associate with being a
woman right yeah it was yeah exactly
definitely more androgynous
looking character or even acting
character there's one thing that i
i will say about this they were
transitioning
while the movies were happening because
i think the matrix
happened over almost a decade right
there's probably a new movie every
two or three years after no but i think
it was happening during
like they were starting to transition
well they were initially just gonna do
the one movie and then it was such a
[ __ ] smash
let's make this a trilogy interesting so
my feeling is
maybe that wasn't the whole point of the
movie yeah but there's no question
whether it was inspired by some of the
[ __ ] that they were feeling yeah
yeah and maybe
maybe transitioning and becoming a woman
when you feel like you're a woman this
is interesting makes your life
way more difficult like taking the red
pill
but it's better to be who you are
despite the difficulty you feel free you
feel free
and if that is what they're trying to
say
if it isn't they should we just killed
that if that's what you're trying to say
i do understand that because i don't
think that anybody would disagree with
that regardless how you feel about trans
yeah your life is way more difficult as
a trans person go through all this [ __ ]
you get treated differently of course
yeah you might not like the way you look
you might not like the way you look you
might not like the person that you are
as a real as you are in your real self
yeah but that freedom is worth it
is absolutely worth it apparently who
knows we'll see what happens yo
this is just a quick question
androgynous people
are they gay androgyny just means they
look
both yeah you can't tell what gender the
gender they were born as
oh i i i think androgyny is just about
appearances it's nothing to do with the
sexual people characteristic i think
short
yeah gay or straight yeah it's just like
tall short light skinned dark skinned
androgynous is like you see a dude that
kind of looks like a chick or a chick
looks like dude like
a lot of these like models have you
noticed lately like sometimes you'll see
like a female model or even a male model
that have like long hair and you're like
is that a guy or a girl like
there's no muscle tone on the dude at
all and uh
so androgyny is just kind of like look
that's it
you